اذا خطوات كلش المتعثره يقابلها خصم واثق
ثقه بقاعده جماهيريه كبيره اثبتت قوتها في
الجوله الاولى سته ايام على المتنافسين
على الرئاسه تركيا لاقناع الناخبين الذين
لم يمنحوا اي منهما اصواتا كافيه لحسم
الدوره الاولى في الرابع عشر من مايو
اردوغان الذي قيل انه تعب من عشرين عاما
في السلطه يدخل الى الجوله الثانيه بتقدم
يبلغ مليونين ونصف المليون صوت على مرشح
المعارضه كمال كلتشتار اوغلو يواصل تنقله
بين المناطق التي ضربها زلزال السادس من
فبراير والتي صوتت باعداد كبيره له في
الجوله الاولى ناثرا وعوده باعاده الاعمار
السريع في هذه المناطق كما يحمل في جعبته
ثلاثه ملايين صوت اضافي هي الاصوات التي
صبت لصالح المرشح الثالث سنان اوغان وهو
من اليمين القومي المتشدد باوغان الذي كان
متريسا حتى اللحظه اعلن انه سيجير
اصواتنا خبيه لاردوغان ما قد يضمن فوز
الرئيس المنتهي ولايته بفارق كبير هذه
المره غير ان خبراء سياسيين اكدوا عدم
حاجه اردوغان لاصوات اوغان بالضروره
مبدلنا استغراب وهم للعب اليمين القومي
دوره صانع الملوك هذه المره واطلاعه
بالدور المعهود للاكراد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات